you ever been intimidated by someone  you're working with intimidated well i  think hugh laurie coming into veep was a  big moment for me  i was intimidated by him because he's a  consummate amazing  dramatic comedic guy yeah  there was also a director named chris  morris i don't know if you know him no  he directed these really subversive  shows called the brass eye and he was  sort of uh  i was way  uh intimidated by him because he has  this very aggressive almost like sasha  baron cone prank style comedy that was  an early  probably influenced sasha and a lot of  stuff that happened over here so he was  just someone i was intimidated by those  are two names that come to mind